c'est un enjeu dont on entend parler le
plus souvent à l'étranger dans les zones
côtières les agriculteurs et la
population en général sont de plus en
plus confrontées aux problèmes de
salinité de l'eau mais c'est une réalité
chez nous aussi et avec les changements
climatiques le problème risque de
prendre de l'ampleur
à Saint-Denis de la bouteille riz dans
le bassin Laurent Magellan élève des
vaches laitières depuis des décennies
même s'il possède un puits pendant
longtemps il a dû faire venir de l'eau
de plus loin Carlos souterraine ici
n'est pas potable les fuir depuis 1960
vierge il était pas utilisé parce qu'il
était trop salé nous on allait chercher
notre eau dans la paroisse voisine pour
avoir de l'eau douce
ça c'est l'eau qui est
rejeté
c'est drôle à dire qu'on a de l'eau à
volonté mais on peut rien faire avec
[Musique]
n’est pas le seul dans cette situation
l'eau souterraine dans la région est
salé à plusieurs endroits
il y avait des un glacier et après à la
déglacer on a une mère qui s'est mis en
place la mère de goldwige et cette mère
a déposé des sédiments
c'est ces dimensions en place c'est ceux
qui sont là dans qu'on peut voir
derrière sous les le sol ce sont des
argiles glaciomarines donc des argiles
qui sont riches en sel donc quand on va
forer dans ces argiles ou que l'eau est
en contact avec ses argiles là elle
libère petit à petit des selles dans
l'eau
Gwenaëlle Chaillou participe à l'effort
collectif de collecte de données sur
l'état des eaux souterraines au Québec
avec son équipe elle étudie la qualité
de l'eau de nombreux puits dans le
bassin Laurent on a appris que on avait
de l'eau mais c'est une ressource qui
est fragile qui est vulnérable en terme
de quantité aussi un terme de qualité
cette ressource là elle est vulnérable
elle est vulnérable au changement
climatique si dans le bassin Laurent on
retrouve par endroit de l'eau salée dans
les eaux souterraines en raison de la
composition des sols en Gaspésie un
phénomène provoque des inquiétudes la
salinisation des aquifères
c'est un problème mondial tous les pays
côtiers qu'on écoute se pose la question
comment est-ce qu'on fait
on prévoit pour le bassin Laurent
Gaspésie une hausse au niveau de la mer
pour d'ici 2100 là d'environ 60 à 80 cm
parce qu'elle bernacci étudie l'érosion
côtière en fonction des changements des
niveaux marins il s'intéresse aussi
particulièrement au phénomène de la
submersion côtière
la submersion contient en fait
l'inondation par les eaux salées
lorsqu'on a un très haut niveau d'eau
donc il y a un franchissement qui se
fait et la partie terrestre est
complètement inondée là par
les vagues de tempête
les changements climatiques risquent
d'accentuer ce phénomène avec des hivers
plus chauds il y a moins de couverts de
glace sur le fleuve et dans le golfe du
Saint-Laurent le chercheur estime que
d'ici 30 ans il y aura 40 jours de moins
de couverts de glace l'hiver
quand on regarde statistiquement ce sont
surtout les tempêtes les plus fortes
énergies se produisent principalement en
hiver donc si on enlève 40 jours de
protection de glace côtières ça fait en
sorte que le littoral va être de plus en
plus exposée à des phénomènes de
submersion côtière et cette eau salée là
va s'infiltrer dans le sol et atteindre
la nappe phréatique dans l'Est du Québec
plus de la moitié de la population vit
le long des côtes si certaines
résidences sont connectées à des
aqueducs plusieurs dépendent depuis
[Musique]
ça soulève différentes questions quand à
notre aménagement et à nos choix qu'on
fait en termes d'aménagement du
territoire de plus en plus on aime avoir
la vue sur l'océan sur le fleuve donc on
va s'installer de plus en plus propre
maintenant on a un choix à faire est-ce
que je vais m'installer là bien que je
sache qu'il y ait un risque de
salinisation parce que le niveau marin
va augmenter
donc les mesures finalement apparaissent
directement sur ce boîtier là pour
régler son problème d'eau salée Magella
diode n'a pas eu d'autres choix que
d'investir des dizaines de milliers de
dollars dans l'installation d'un système
de traitement d'eau par osmose inversés
l'équipement comme la rouille ou les
autres mais c'est minime à comparer d'un
manque d'eau
à des alternatives comme le smooth pour
transformer l'eau salée c'est
merveilleux
[Musique]